[Música]
rodó por el país con una bicicleta de
bambú él es ya cooper es candidato por
el movimiento indígena pachakutik es el
único aspirante por los pueblos nativos
el abogado de 51 años tiene cuatro
maestrías y centra su propuesta y la
defensa del medio ambiente cuando fue en
pandemia él hizo algo que la gente jamás
se animó paulo de refuerzo y por eso
mismo ahora tiene mi apoyo y tiene por
mí mi voz
ya q pérez cultivó su capital político
durante las protestas de octubre de 2019
que iniciaron en rechazo a las medidas
económicas del actual presidente
lenin moreno sabemos que ya q pérez
nunca fue un líder histórico ni surgido
del movimiento indígena por lo tanto
hay que ver en el futuro pero también
podría ser un topo para el movimiento
indígena porque finalmente lo que está
representando no es el proyecto
histórico del movimiento indígenas de la
conaie está representando un proyecto
personal y un proyecto que tiene muchos
vínculos con la derecha en ecuador el 7%
de la población es indígena y si no
llega a segunda vuelta una alianza con
algunos de los candidatos podría
inclinar la intención de voto a pérez se
le relaciona con la derecha si queremos
ser el ecuador igual que venezuela estar
gobernado
a un presidente que va a ser igual que
maduro
que no va a tener una brújula que no va
a tener un horizonte que nos va a llevar
a una crisis insostenible que nos va a
acabar con la dolarización en 2017 pérez
ya dio su apoyo al candidato de derecha
y erbol aso pero recientemente se ha
desvinculado de él confiado en que
llegará segunda vuelta se niega a
anunciar a quien dará su apoyo queda por
ver si el activista podrá capitalizar el
cansancio de los ciudadanos en los
partidos tradicionales y convertirse en
el primer mandatario indígena del
ecuador